its mission accomplished that NASA the
very first planetary defense operation
has successfully struck a harmless Space
Rock orbiting an asteroid millions of
kilometers from Earth the goal was to
nudge the little Moon into a new orbit
it was an unprecedented dress rehearsal
for the day an asteroid ever finds
itself on a collision course with our
planet
oh my gosh oh wow awaiting visual
confirmation a direct hit millions of
kilometers from Earth
the world's first ever planetary defense
Mission a success that is far from a
coincidence
NASA is going on the offensive tens of
thousands of asteroids orbit the sun
many capable of wiping out a city
while none of them are in imminent
threat to the Earth the agency decided
it's time to test its planetary defense
systems the idea behind dot the double
asteroid redirection test was to launch
a small spacecraft toward a space rock
smash into it at high speed and alter
its course
this inaugural planetary defense test
mission marks a major moment in human
history for the first time ever we will
measurably change the orbit of a
Celestial body in the universe doing so
has clear benefits in ensuring
Humanity's ability to deflect a
potential threatening asteroid in the
future
NASA proved it could hit a small object
in space
a follow-up Mission will check up on the
target Rock in four years to see how
much its orbit has changed
but first it is time for celebrations
I'm joined Now by zofrika Barney from DW
science so the uh great to see that they
managed to uh nudge that little Moon as
we put it uh what would happen though if
a big asteroid came our way
oh Ben you want to hit me with a big
question straight away okay uh if a big
asteroid hit Earth you may lose a city
or two you may Wipe Out the dinosaurs
and of course we are today's dinosaurs
so that may be what will happen but NASA
is very very determined to say that
there are no immediate threats I mean
they use this term in the foreseeable
future in terms of Space Science the
foreseeable future is a shed load of
time so there are in the asteroid belt
which is reasonably close to us between
Mars and Jupiter
um about just over a million known
asteroids but none of those asteroids
the ones that we know about are an
immediate threat to Earth as it is um so
it's a big threat it could happen you
know but it doesn't have to happen
tomorrow so so would you say the the
huge price tag attached and all that
work and science and research is
Justified
I think
personally it probably is Justified look
I mean you know the administrators at
Nasa Bill Nelson uh palmel Roy have both
you know said this is a success what
they've succeeded in doing is showing
that this automated system has been able
to a determine between two different
asteroids or you know one orbiting the
other done that on its own it's taken
pictures this camera dracoi Draco I've
got to say don't you love the names they
use crack over this camera so they can
Target an asteroid they can hit it On
Target they've done that whether it's
the success or not and that will come to
answer your question about whether this
price tag of I think is about 330
million dollars over a seven year period
is worth it well we'll see that it's a
bit like a when you drop an analog watch
it has been likened to that you know the
cogs get knocked out but you won't see
that immediately so it might take days
it may take weeks and they've been very
clear NASA and um the Applied Physics
laboratory at John's Hopkins they're
both looking at this of course the
entire into International Space
Community is looking at this with ground
telescopes they'll it'll take time to
see whether it's worth it one other
thing I'd like to say is this is that
you know these things aren't costed
years in advance so okay is the money
worth it in the middle of an economic
crisis who knows but they had to go
ahead now it was on target it was on
plan
um we will see we are really interested
in asteroids actually because of the
crises that we see on Earth you know we
we need to see whether we protect
ourselves but also they do hold valuable
resources we think you know like nickel
and iron things that we may use for
space habitations but also to bring back
to Earth and space missions have done
that you know brought back minerals so
you know I'm not an economist but it's
fascinating stuff it's good for
knowledge and it could also bring back
economic benefit to us so in that sense
you know depending on what side of the
fence you're on it was worth it yeah so
they really briefly um just how
difficult is it to do something like
that if you can sum it up in a sentence
would you say a shot in the dark
yeah
I mean it is you know just just
launching a rocket any your your common
or what is it gun or common you know
rocket just launching a satellite is
difficult they can go wrong look at
Artemis three they've just knocked off
the third uh launch attempt it is really
difficult everything you know things can
go wrong at every turn so um it is
difficult they've done it this bit it's
a successful now we'll see if
Applause all around Ben also to zulfica
Barney from DW science